Hi, I'm Beau Carnes with free code camp.org. I'm
going to show you how to code a discord bot with
JavaScript that runs completely in the cloud
for free. I already made a course about coding
a discord bot with Python. And you can get
the link to that up here in the corner or
down in the description. We're gonna use a few
different tools, including the discord API,
a few JavaScript libraries, and a cloud computing
platform called replique. You probably already
know what discord is, and what a discord
bot is, since you're watching this tutorial,
but just in case you don't let me give you a brief
overview. discord is an app used for real time
text chat, discord servers are set up by people
and generally are focused on a certain community.
Many groups and organizations have discord
servers for people to chat with each other.
A Discord server often has many channels, which
are different rooms that you can chat in. A
discord bot, is a user in your Discord server that
is controlled by a program instead of a person.
You can code a discord bot to make it do whatever
you want. There are many things discord bots
are often used for. They can be used to chat,
respond to messages, manage servers, play music,
and more. You can also use a web hooks with a
discord bot to do things like give real time
updates on a GitHub repository. The bow we will
create in this course is called encouraged bot, it
can tell people inspirational quotes that it gets
from an API. Also, when the user says a sad word,
the bot will respond with an encouraging phrase.
Users can also add or remove encouraging phrases
that the bot uses directly from Discord. The first
step for creating a discord bot is to make sure
you have a Discord server to add the bot to, you
may already have one. But let me just show you
how to set one up really quick in case you don't
already have one. So you're going to have to go
to discord comm and log into Discord. And then you
just click the plus button here to add a server.
And I'll say for me and my friends. And I'll just
call it robot family server. OK, let's create
that. And now we have our server. Okay, so before
we can code our bot using Python, and using the
discord API, we must first create a discord bot
account right within Discord. So you're going to
have to go to the discord developer portal. I'll
put the link in the description, but it's just
discord comm slash developers slash applications.
So once you're on the applications page, you're
going to click this new applications button. And
then we're going to create a name for it. This bot
is going to send friendly encouragement to people
from in Discord. So I'm going to call it encourage
bot. Okay, I'll create that. Okay, now I'm going
to go to the bot tab here. And then I am going to
click Add bot and say yes, do it. Okay, we'll keep
the default the default settings as a public bot,
and then we won't require the OAuth to grant the
code grant. So now the the bot has been created.
The next step is to copy the bot token. Okay,
so I'll just click Copy to copy the token,
we're going to need that later. Now
this token is your bots password.
So make sure not to share it with anybody. It
could allow someone to log into your bot and do
all sorts of bad things. And it could even allow
someone to mess with your server. And also,
you can obviously regenerate the token if
they accidentally get shared. So now we have
to invite the bot to our server, we have the
bot user, and we have to get into our server.
To do that, we're gonna have to create an invite
URL for it. So let's go to the off to tab here.
And now we're just gonna go to the scope section.
Since this is a bot, we'll just click Buy here.
Now we have to scroll down a little bit more and
go to the bot permissions section. So we'll choose
the permissions we want for the bot. Our bot
is going to be mainly used for text messages.
So we don't need a lot of permissions. So your
bot may do different things. But let's just
choose some of these here. Actually will do all
of them on this line except send TTS messages. Now
you do need to be careful with this administrator
permissions. If you give your bot administrative
permissions it has a it will be able to control
your server in ways that you may not actually
want. And then I guess the last one we need to
add is the view channels are bots going to have
to view the channels. So after selecting the
appropriate permissions, we'll click the Copy
button right here. And this will copy a URL
that can be used to add the bot to a server.
And I guess we'll also have to recopy the
back key, we copy the back key earlier,
but now it's been re copied with this URL. So
we'll have to come back later to get the back key.
But now let's just open up a new tab, and I'm
gonna go to this URL. Okay, so now we have to
choose a server, we want to add the bot to I'll
choose robot family server, the only option,
but you will probably have more than more options.
So we'll click Continue. And we want to approve
that we want to do all these things, we want
to authorize the bot for all these things.
And I'm not a robot and the bot is authorized.
That means the bot has joined the server. So
if we actually go over into our server, we can see
encouraged bot just slid into the server. But also
you see over here that the bot is offline, it's
not going to be online till we write our code that
creates the bot and run the code. And speaking of
code, it's time to start that. Now I said earlier
that you don't have to install anything, you don't
have to use any software except your web browser,
we are going to be creating the entire discord bot
right in the cloud on replicat. The website for
replique is our epl.it. And replica is an online
ID e that you can just use in your web browser.
So it makes it a lot easier to code things if
you don't have to install any special software
on your computer. And then you can log into
it from multiple browsers, multiple computers,
and then you can easily access your code and your
programs no matter what computer you're using.
So we're going to make our bet on this. And then
it will also be completely hosted in the cloud,
we can even run the bot on this website. So we
don't have to run it on our local computer. And
that will make it so we can keep the bot running.
Even if our computer shuts down, or we're gonna
where we close the browser tab or anything like
that, I'll show you how to make the bot so it'll
keep running in the background continuously.
And then you don't have to worry about it.
If you don't already have account, you're
going to sign up. But I'm going to log in here,
I'm going to show you how to use replique to
create the bot from scratch. But just in case you
click the link in the description to the completed
bot, you're going to want to click fork here.
And you don't really want to start editing, you
probably want to fork it and then create your
own copy, and then start editing instead of trying
to request edit my copy. Okay, this is replique.
So let me show you how to start a new project.
We're just going to click on new new repple here.
And then I'm going to be using node j s. So
I'll click on node j s. And then if we want,
we can name it or you can use the default
name, I'm going to call it encourage bot
js, and then create repple. We're going to be
using the discord.js node library to write the
code for the bot. This go js is an API wrapper for
discord that makes it easier to create a discord
bot, and no GS or JavaScript. Okay, we're in our
project, you can see that we have our files here
we have our code that we're going to write here.
And then we have a console over on the side. And
then there's some different tabs, we are only
going to be mainly using the Files tab here. But
we'll also be using the database tab later.
But for now, let's get started. So first,
we're going to add the discord.js library. So
I'll add const discord equals require discord.js.
Now repple, it will automatically install
this dependency when you press the button the
Run button. So that's one cool thing about
repple is that dependencies are installed
automatically. And if you ever have a problem,
you can always go into the shell. And you can
install anything manually in the shell. But
let's go back over to the console. This core.js
revolves around the concept of events. An event
is something you listen to and then respond to.
For example, when a message happened, you will
receive an event about it that you can respond to,
we're going to start by making a very simple bot.
This is a bot that's going to respond to messages.
This is taken directly from the discord.js doc
documentation. So we'll start by making a very
simple one. And then we'll continue to add to
and make it more complex and make it work for our
purposes. So after this first line, we need to get
a client const client And equals new discord dot
client. So this is our discord client that
we'll be working with to connect to our Discord
server. This is the client for the discord.js
library. Okay, I talked about different events.
So our client is going to respond to different
types of events. One event is the ready event,
a ready event means that the bot has successfully
connected to our Discord server and is ready to do
more things. So let's add code now to respond
to the ready event. So you start with client
that on so on what on what event?
Well, the event is going to be ready.
So on the ready event, once it's ready to start
working, once it's connected to our server,
it's going to call this callback function.
So let's make this callback function here.
And we're just going to console
dot log something console dot
log, blog and as. And then when I get the
client name, or the username, the name of
the bot client, that user dot tag. Okay, now we're
going to respond to a different event, the event
is a message. So whenever the bot sees a message
in the discord server, it will get the message
event and it will do something whenever there's
a message, so client that on message. And then
it will call this callback function, we'll get
access to the message through this parameter here.
And we're going to check to see what the message
actually is. message content is the text of the
message. So we're going to check for this
example, if the message is the word Ping.
And if so, then we'll do something. So we're going
to reply message reply. Pong. So it will the our
bot will actually reply with another message
in the chat, and the message will be Pong.
Okay, now that we have our, our event set
up the ready event in the message event,
we need to have our client login to the server. So
to log into the server, we'll do client dot login.
Now here, we need to put our token. But we're
not going to actually you could put your token
as a string here. Remember, the token is a thing
when we created the bot on the developer page,
we copied the token. And if you don't have that
anymore, you can go back to the developer page and
copy the token. Again, you can put the token as a
string right here. But we're not going to do that.
And the reason is, because anything on repple,
it can be accessed by anyone on the internet.
So we don't want anybody to be able to have access
to our token that's like a password for our bot.
And then anybody could actually use our bot to do
anything that they wanted. We don't want that. So
we need to have a figured out we need a way to
keep our token a secret. And the way we're going
to do that is when it within an environment
variable repple, it has a special way of doing
that, we are going to create our environment
variable in just a second. Let's access it right
now. And then we'll create it. So to access
a environment variable, where we do process
dot E and V dot and then the name of the
environment variable, which in this case is going
to be token. So now we have to find a place to put
this. So this is how it works in redplum, we're
gonna create a new file, and I'm gonna call it dot
E and V. Anything in a dot E and V file is hidden
from the rest of the world. And you can see we
already have it here. So we have the word token,
you're gonna have to put the word token and then
an equal sign. And then you paste in your token
that you got for your bot. So in this case, this
is my token. And now that we have our token stored
in our environmental variable, it can get the
token and the dot E and V file. Like I said,
it cannot be accessed by it, nobody can see except
you in the other file. Everyone can see it but
the dot EMB only you can see it and that's how
we can get that token that nobody else can see.
I guess all of you just saw because I just
saw it on my screen, but more usually,
you know Not to be making a video so nobody will
actually see the actual environment variable.
So it's time I'm going to run this program.
Okay, it says we're logged in. So that worked.
Maybe you may have had a problem if somehow it
didn't automatically install discord dot j s. In
that case, like I said, you can install it in
this shell. But everything worked for me so and
I am going to go over to my Discord server
right now and see what it looks like. Okay,
show is that encouraged by is logged in. So
I'm going to do a chat, I'm gonna type in
ping pong. And see since it's a reply, it says
My name because encouraged by replying to me
and saying Pong. So it worked. We have a bot, and
it works. Now that we have a basic bot working,
we'll improve it. It's called encouraged bot for
a reason. The bot will respond with a message
of encouragement whenever someone sent a message
containing a sad or depressing word. Anyone will
be able to add encouraging messages for the bot
to use, and the user submitted messages will be
stored in the replique database. The bot will also
return a random inspirational quote from an API.
When someone types a message in spire into the
chat. We'll start with adding the Inspire feature,
we're gonna get inspirational quotes
from an API called Zen quotes.io.
Now this, it could actually work with any API,
you can use any API and just any API that's
going to return JSON or any sort of string, you
can use. And then you can get that information.
And then you can actually return the string as a
message with your bot. But I just found this is in
quotes that I owe is a easy way to get a quote
and encouraging or motivating quote, that we can
return with our bond. So since we are going
to be calling this API, we're going to need
to import the node fetch module. So up here,
I am going to do const. Fetch equals require
node fat. So we will be able to use that to call
the API. And now let's make a function called get
quote, that will be able to be called to get
a quote from the API. So function, get quote,
inside this function, we are going to return the
quote. And inside this function, we are going
to fetch the quote, and actually, we're going to
return it so return, and then I will do my fetch
command, fetch. And then here is where we put
the URL, HTTPS, colon slash less than quotes.io
slash API. Let's make more room here. So
you can see everything that I'm typing in
x n is going to be slash random. Okay, after
we fetch the information, do dot then this
is an asynchronous call. So first, it gets the
information, it may not get it right away, so but
it's going to wait till it gets information from
this URL, then it's going to do something with
that data. So let's put the callback function,
they'll call that will call after get that data.
We are going to return the result.
But we're going to convert it to JSON.
And then we are going to do something else with
that data that JSON that data that's returned.
We're going to return we're going to format it
in the exact way we want it to be formatted.
So we have the data. And let me just type in this.
Okay, to figure out exactly what I want
to return here and how to format this,
I had to use trial and error. So I
got the information from this URL,
and I converted JSON. And then I figured out
that the Q is quote, and the A is the author. So
this is going to put the quote here. And then it's
going to be there'll be a dash and there'll be the
author, you'll see exactly what it looks like when
we test this out. But so this is going to this is
going to return a random inspirational quote. And
to get the information into the format I wanted.
It's going to look like that. And so it's going to
return the quote when someone calls this function.
So let's update our message. Here, so it will
return a quote at the right time, we're going
to add something where, first we're gonna add a
new thing, we're gonna check to see if the message
is from the bot. If the bot ever says anything we
don't want the bot to, to respond to itself. So if
message dot author dot bot, that means if the
bot is author of the message, just return.
So we're not going to do anything in that
case. But if message content equals, well,
it's not gonna be equal, and ping anymore, we're
looking for the word inspire. So if it senses
that there's a message that's, that's inspire,
then we're gonna do the get quote, function,
get quote, that then, so you see where, where
respond, we're returning the risk, the what's
the result of this fetch. And so this is also a
promise that we can then this is an async call. So
once we get the result, then we're going to do
something, then we are going to take the quote
and we'll do a message dot channel, dot send.
So this is going to send a message to the whole
channel, and the message is going to be the
quote. Okay, let's try this out. First of all,
stop it because it was already running before
but we just started again for the new code.
And I'll wait till it shows it's logged in here.
Oh, see is installing the node fetch module now.
Okay, we're logged in. Okay, now
I will type dollar sign inspire.
They say love is the best investment The
more you give, the more you get in return,
Audrey Hepburn. Wow, I feel very inspired now.
And just so you know, it doesn't respond
like that to anything. If I say hello,
it doesn't have response, the only response if it
sees dollar sign and spider. Now we will implement
the feature where the bot respond with encouraging
messages when a user posts a message with a sad
word. So first, we need to create an array that
contains the sad words that the bot will respond
to. So I'm gonna go up here, and I'm going to
create an array, it's going to be called sad
words. And then I'll just
have a list of sad words.
Now you can use any list you want, and
any sad words about the sad, depressed,
unhappy, angry. And we'll do those. But
you can add more to this list if you
want. Now we'll add an array of encouraging
messages that the bot will respond where. So
let's add another array called
encouragements, const encouragements
Cheer up. Hang in there. You
are a great person, or bot.
Unlike before, feel free to add any phrases you
want, or just change them up. I'm just using these
three items for now, because later we'll add the
ability for users to add more encouraging phrases
for the bots to for the bot to use. So now we need
to update our bot to use the two lists we created.
So let's go down to the message function, we're
going to add another section here. And we're
going to add a section that's going to check to
see if the message contains a word from the sad
word list. And then if a sad word is found, the
bot will send a random message of encouragement.
So let's add that. And this time, I just paste
it in some code, and we're going to go over it.
So this is how we're going to check if the
message contains a word and the sad words list.
So we start with sad words, that sum, this is an
array method. Let me show you what it's gonna do.
We're going to go through each item in the array,
or in this case, a word. And then we're going to
check if message content dot includes if the
message includes the word, and we're going to
do that for every word in the list. And this sad
words that Psalm is going to return true if one or
more of these things are true. And so if at least
one of those words in the list is in the middle
It's going to be true. So then it's going to run
the code here. So first we're going to create a
single encouragement. So the encouragement
list, we have the encouragement list,
and then we want a random element. So this is how
we get a random element. Mat that floor rounds
down math dot random time, it's encouragements
that link. So this is just a way to get a random
index number for the encouragements array. And
then we're going to get that random encouragement,
and then message reply, encouragement. So
it's going to return that encouragement.
Okay, let's stop this. And then we're going
to restart it. Okay, we can test it. I am sad.
says Beau Carnes. Hang in there. It's very
encouraging. Thank you encouraged bought,
I am happy now. And it doesn't respond
at all. Because now that I'm happy,
it doesn't need to respond. But now I'm
feeling good. I'm feeling depressed.
Cheer up. Oh, that makes me feel a lot better.
And you can see us getting random phrases,
hang in there, cheer up, and include my name here.
Because it's a reply. If we go back to our code,
you can see that it's a message dot reply. Anytime
it's a reply, it's going to include the name,
the person who said the message, and then
the new message, which is the encouragement.
Okay, you basically know enough to
make your own bot. And you can go to
the discord.js documentation to find out even
more features you can do with your discord bot.
But now we're going to learn right now how to
implement more advanced features with this bot,
and store data using the rep database. So
let's make it possible to update the bot
right from Discord. A user should be able to
add more encouraging messages for the bot to use
when it detects the sad word, we're going to be
using replicates built in database to store user
submitted messages. The database is a key value
store that's built into every replica. So if you
click right here, it says database, it's going to
show you all these database commands you can use.
So you're always going to have to import
the database at the top, you can create a
new database, we're actually going to put some
of these commands right now. So if we just go
up to the top here, and then right under my other
require, I'm going to click insert here. And it's
just going to put this code right in here, current
database equals require, and then it's going to
get this database library. Okay, now we have to
create a new database. So we'll separate these
require statements from these other new statements
here. So I'm going to create a new database.
And when we run the code, this
will automatically install.
And if it doesn't, or if you're doing it on your
local machine, you can just go over to the shell
and do npm install, and then use this for the
name here. So what we're going to do down here
after the encouragements, we're
going to initialize the database
with these three encouragements. We're
gonna just add those to the to the database
if they're not already in the database. So
this is how we're gonna do that. dB dot get
encouragements. So we're going to get the
encouragement that are already in the database.
Well, if this is the first time this program
runs, there won't be any in there. But if the
program has run previously in our there's already
encouraged us in the database, then we'll get the
list of encouragements that are in the database.
So this is the key, enter this key key value
pairs. So this is the key and then we're going to
get the value which to start off with would be no,
but after we get the encouragement, then
we are going to take those encouragements.
And then we're going to do this.
I'm going to put this function here.
If we're going to check if there are no
encouragements, if there are no encouragements or
if the encouragements that link
is less than one. So if there's
zero encouragements, then we're going to add the
encouragements. So there will always be at least
something to encourage people with. So and by
the way, the reason why we have both of these
is because the first time this runs encouragements
will be no but later encourages could be zero.
So an either case, we want to do DB dot set.
We're going to set the encouragements key. We're
going to set this to be the encouragements. Well,
we want to set to be these encouragements, but
we're already using this variable here. And we're
going to use encouragements later. So this is what
let's just change this to be called starter
encouragements. So this is now this starter
encouragements, and we're going to set these
encouragements to be the starter encouragements.
users will be able to add custom
encouraging messages for the bot to use
directly from the discord chat. Before we add
new commands to the bot, let's add to let's
create two helper functions that will add custom
messages to the database and delete the messages.
So right after this, we're going to
create a helper function function.
Function update encouragements and it's going
to take one argument and encouraging message.
And so first, we're gonna get the list of
current encouraging messages, db dot get
encouragement. And then after
we get those encouragements,
then we're going to take those encouragements.
And in this function, we're gonna do something
with them. So we're gonna do encouragements
dot push, we're gonna push the new message on to
this list onto this array. encouraging message.
Now, we're going to do DB dot set,
we're going to add this to the database
with the new the new encouraging message on it. So
encouragements that's the key, and the new value
for that key is going to be encouragements. Okay,
now we have to make another function to delete
the encouragements. So function, delete, incur
encouragement. And this is going to take an index,
the index in the array that needs to be deleted.
So first, we're going to
get it's actually gonna be
somewhat similar. So I'm going to
get just copy this and paste this in.
But we are not going to be pushing any new any
new thing here. So what we're going to do instead
is if encouragement, that length is greater than
the index, we're only only good delete something
if the index is is actually an appropriate index.
So if the length is greater than the index,
then it's part of the index will actually apply
to this array. What we're going to do is incur
encouragements dot splice, this is how you remove
an item from an array index one. So at the index,
we're going to remove one item, and then we're
going to just move this up. I'm going to cut this
and put it here. So now we're going to set the
encouragement again to be this new encouragements
array that has the encouragements
remove that we want to remove.
Okay, let's update this section now. So now we
have to make sure that we are using our list from
the database when we return a message when there's
a sad word detected. So let's add something here.
We are going to have to get the the
messages from the database. So DB
dot get encouragement. That then encouragement.
And now all this code, I'm just gonna
cut that and then put it in here.
And this is actually should be encouraged minutes.
Okay, now let's make it so our bot will respond
to two new commands. So, if message dot content
dot starts starts with. So if the content starts
with dollar sign new, then we are going to do
something. So first we have to figure out what the
new the new messages. So the person will be typing
dollar sign new space, and then they'll put their
new message that should be should be added to the
list of encouragements. So the encouraging message
is going to equal message dot content dot split,
new one. So this is the method. And
that split is a JavaScript string
method. And we're going to split at this
and make sure there's a space at the end,
because the person's going to type in dollar
sign new space. And then we want anything after
that to be the new message. So index one in the
array, because this is going to create an array
index one will be anything after this. So
we'll get the encouraging message. And then
update encouragements with
the encouraging message.
And then after we do that, we can send a message
to the whole channel, message dot channel, dot
send. So our bot is about to send this
message new, encourage Jane and her urging,
there we go. Message added. Oh, see right here.
Encouraging. There we go. New encouraging message
added. Okay, now we have to do the same thing with
delete. So I'm just going to copy this whole thing
because it will be kind of similar, and then paste
it here. Now we're looking to see if the message
the user types in starts with D l for delete. And
we're splitting it D L. And this is now going to
be the index, the person is going to type in
dollar sign t l space and they're going to put
a number and the number is going to be the
index of the array that should be deleted,
sends it to number we should do parse int to
convert this to from a string to an int. So
parse int, and then I'm going to put this
in parentheses. So parse int, and instead of
update encouragements, we're going to be doing
the leet encouragement. And then I can put the
index here, and then message that child
that send new encouraging message deleted.
Okay, we can test this out here. So I'll
run the program. And we're logged in.
I am sad. Hang in there. That's really
encouraging. Well, let's become even
more encouraging, because I'm going to add a new
message. You are a great person, and also a great
singer. Hmm, that would make me feel encouraged.
Okay, how about nice avatar? And how about
that was a wonderful message. Okay, now I'm
going to see if it will use one of those new
messages we added. So I am sad. That was
a wonderful message. I am depressed. I
guess that was a wonderful message. Is that
encouraging if I'm saying that I'm sad, but
you are a great person and also a great singer.
Now let's see if we can delete one of these.
So let's delete. I'll do Dell and I'll put index
zero. And let me just delete a few of them.
Now we should have deleted all three of
the initial messages. So if what's sad
let's see if we see any of the initial messages.
We're not seeing any we're only seeing the new
ones because all the initial ones were deleted.
Okay, now we're going to add the ability to get
a list of user submitted messages right from
Discord. And we'll we will add the ability To turn
off and on whether the bot responds to sad words.
So that change whether it responds or not, we're
going to add a new variable or a new new key
value pair to the database. So let me scroll
up a little bit. And right before this where
we initialize the encouragements key value pair,
let's do the same thing with another one DB that
get responding. So this is a variable
called responding or the key value pair.
So as we're trying to figure out, if the
bot should be responding or not, then
value will get whatever the the initial value is.
And let's check if it exists yet.
If If value equals equals null,
that means that this is the first time the
program has run, so it's not in the database yet.
Then let's set it to something set, set it to
responding is going to equal or be set to true.
Now, this will only happen if the value
goes no. So if you run the program,
and you've set this to false, the next time
the program runs, it won't then be set to true,
it will still be saved in the database,
even if you stop and restart the program.
Okay, so the whole point of that was to change
whether it responds to the sad words or not.
So let's add something else
here. dB that get responding.
And we're trying to see if the, if the bots
be responding or not, then respond responding.
Now we're going to take this whole thing here.
And it's going to be inside this other section,
and let me indent this. So now we're
gonna check if responding is true. And
this is true. Alright, so be responding. There we
go. So now we're checking with for two things to
be true before it sends the encouraging message.
Okay, let's go down and we're going to add two
command to more commands, one of them will be to
list all the encouraging messages. And the other
command will be to change the responding
status to either true or false on or off.
So if message dot content dot starts
with, if it starts with less list,
then we're going to list all the messages. So
first, we have to get the messages DB dot get
encouragements dot then and encouragement.
And then actually this week
called encouragements methods dot
channel dot send encouragements. So send all
the encouragement to the channel as a message.
Okay, so for the next one, you
just copy this first line here.
If message content that starts with and
this time it's going to be responding.
So that means we're chaining the command
is to change whether the bot is going to
respond or not. So let's get the value first
value equals message dot content dot split.
responding with the space at the
end, one, this is just like before,
and the value is either going to be
true or false. So if value.to lowercase
equals equals equals True then DB that
sec responding to true. Also message dot
channel dot send. Chris respond. risk.
Oh, wait a second, Reese bonding is on
else. So if it's anything but true, we'll assume
it's false. So let me just copy this here,
else set responding to false, and the
message will be responding is off.
The code for the bot is complete.
We're gonna test it out one more time. And
then I will show you how to make the bot,
how to set the bot to run continuously,
or run the program and it's logged in.
Okay, let's just try to do a list. Let's
see if I can add something to the list.
And I'll do the list again. And adds the item I
added the item. Yes, and now it's on the list. Now
it's even easier to delete things. So I'm going
to delete that was a wonderful message because
we don't want to respond with that if someone
says a sad message. So I will do tell that's
the index two. And then I will do list
and oh, you know this is wrong new encouraging
message deleted. That doesn't make sense.
This is just be encouraging message deleted.
I don't know why I didn't notice that before.
So let's update that to encouraging.
That's going to be new. There we go. Look
looks like I have a few spelling errors here.
Okay, responding. And then down here. We have
responding. I don't know why I can't spell
this. Okay, let's play that again. Hopefully
we don't have any errors. or run that again. Keep
saying play because it looks like a play button.
And now I will list
and it's gone. It doesn't say that was a wonderful
message anymore. Sad. Oh, I didn't mean it. But I
shouldn't put the dollar sign but it should
still respond because it has the word sad.
Oh, but it's not there's no
space before it's so let's just
Oh, it is responding. Nice avatar said
you're a great person and also a great
singer. Now let's see if we can turn it
off and on. So responding, false or false.
Responding is off. So if I type in sad, it doesn't
respond. Now I can turn it back on responding.
respond, thing true. Responding
is on. So if I type in depressed,
you are a great person and also a great singer.
It works. We've created the bot, we've tested
it, everything works. Okay, so our bot is done.
But there's one more thing I want to show you,
which is how to make the bot run continuously
as it is if you ever Close your eyes. So if you
run this bot right now if I run this bot and
ever close my tab or close my browser, it will
stop running. But we want to make it so it'll
just run in the background. So you don't even
have to have your computer on for the discord
bot to be running. So there's two ways to do
it. One way is just to click right up here.
And you can see it says this repple can be kept
always on and there normally would be just a an on
button here to keep an eye on so just keep running
in the background. Even if you close things
however you do have to upgrade. So you do have
to upgrade to the paid plan to have this built
in way to keep the repple always on. So here's the
pricing for the hacker plan that repple offers.
You get five rebels that are always on if you
if you get it you also get a bunch of storage,
extra memory more speed, and soon you'll even
get offline rebels and $7 a month is pretty
reasonable. It's just like you would pay for
any hosting replique made this course possible
through a grant. And they're also offering three
months free of this hacker plan to the first
1000 people that clink that click the link in the
description with the coupon code. But like I said,
there's also a way to get your rep to be always
on for free without even signing up for this.
And I'm going to show you that right now. If you
run your bot and repple it and then close the tab,
it's running in your bot was stopped running.
However, there is a workaround. So the workaround
without having to pay anything is that replica
will continue running a web server even after the
tab is closed. But even a web server will only run
for up to an hour without any use. So to keep the
bot running continuously, we'll use another free
service called uptime robot. That's the uptime
robot.com, it can be set up to ping the bar to
web server on rappeler every five minutes. And
then with constant pings, the bot will never enter
the sleeping stage and will just keep running. So
we have to do two things, we have to create the
web server and replicate and set up uptime robot
to continually ping the web server. So let me
show you how we're going to create the webserver.
First of all, I'm going to create a new file,
and just click Add File and this is going to be
called server dot j s. Okay, and now we're going
to be using express to create the web server.
Okay, so we'll do const.
Express, equals require, Express.
And then we to create the server
so const server equals Express.
Now that we have the server, we need
to create a route. And the route is the
thing that is that's going to be pinged from
uptime robot. So here we go, server, dot all.
So this creates a new route at just slash
like just at your root domain. And it's
going to respond to all HTTP requests.
That's what this all is. So like get
put, post, and it's just going to say it's going
to send back bot is running. So now that we have
the server ready, we have to create a function
that starts the server. So function, and we're
just going to be calling it keep alive because
it's going to keep alive our replique instance.
Server dot, listen. We'll listen at Port 3000.
And then we're just going to log something.
Whoops, to be equal sign.
Console dot log server is ready.
So when this keepalive function is run,
it's going to the server is gonna start
listening at Port 303,000. And it's going
to log servers ready. And now we just have
to export this so we can import it and run
it from our bot file. So module dot exports.
Equals keep alive. Okay, now let's make sure that
when our bot runs, automatically runs this server.
So let me go into our index dot j, s. And
then at the very top here const keep alive
and require. And then we're just going to
require the server that we just created
server. And then down here,
right before our client logs in,
keep alive. So we'll start our server
will start that server function.
Okay, now let's run this and
see if the server starts.
Oh, actually, we need to make keep alive,
not keep alive ever. So let's try that again.
And we can tell that the server started
because it opened up a new window here and
it says bot is running. So I'm going to copy
there's a link right here which I'm going to
select and copy. This is our server link that
we're going to have to put into uptime robot.
So let's go set this up on uptime robot to ping
our server every five minutes. Okay, I uptime
robot.com. And you're either gonna have to
register or login. And once you get logged in,
you'll see this dashboard and there's this
add new monitor here. So I'm gonna click that.
And monitor type, this is going to be an HTTPS
monitor. And I can just call this encouraged bot.
And then I'll just paste in the
URL that I copied from our applet.
And then it's on every five minutes.
And then, if I want I can select myself to notify
if you want to be notified when something goes
wrong, but you know, I'm not going to notify
myself so I'm just going to do create monitor
and it's created. Now, our bot will continue
running after a close the tab or close the window.
Even if my computer is turned off. The
discord bot will still just keep running.
We're done we learn how to create a discord bot.
We learn how to make it continually run. And
now you know enough to start customizing this
and creating your own bot. I would recommend
checking out the discord.js documentation
to learn even more commands you can add
Okay, you reach the end, go and create your
own bots. But remember, use your code for good